he's wearing a throwback Mike Schmidt as
a matter of fact you cannot spell
Philippi without fili
that's right Brian Philippi good to see
you here
good to see you is that the first time
you've ever heard that I just it kind of
hit me that your first the first your
first six letters of your last name is
Fillie yeah I've never heard someone
else say it but it's something I've
thought in my head so many times so now
you've got this Schmidt throw but what
from what year is this throwback leave
it's a 79 should I show the back of it
throat okay you get the back of it yeah
it's like a zip-up it's used to wear
these this is like they used to zip up
their jerseys because I went online once
I bought this uh-huh and found photos of
the players wearing those same jurors
which meant your guy growing up is that
what you were growing up or what kind of
was yeah where did you three date you a
little bitter no not at all because 1980
I was six years old and I remember I was
staying up way past my bedtime I
remember hiding behind a piece of
furniture so my parents wouldn't see me
so I could watch some of that World
Series and of course that was Carlton
and Mike Smith the Wiis kids right
wasn't that what they were called cuz
Rose was on the team and wasn't Joe
Morgan on this right yeah he was yeah
instead of the whiz kids they were these
kids because they were so old right but
they were all just dynamic yeah Schmidt
is just one of the all-time greats he is
man he is he is you know it's funny
Schmidt the first sports cast I ever did
in my life my entire life Ryan she can
tell you this about Mike Schmidt was in
summer camp the Trails End camp in in
Beach Lake Pennsylvania in Pennsylvania
and I woke up before revelry and I got
my ducks in a row I got all my
information on how I got it cause it's
way before Internet how old were you
gosh I had have been about this might
have been 1980 it might have been right
around then I might have been about 10
11 okay really young kid and I just
wanted to be the sportscaster and
they're like fine you could do the
sports before like when you wake up the
whole camp you do the sports mm-hmm on
the loudspeaker whole camp heard it and
Mike Schmidt hit hit a home run before
and I was so nervous
I forgot to say the M in Mike Schmidt's
last name so that's the word I said on
was one and done because they thought I
was just like camp misspoke is always so
nervous yeah and also he was kind of a
tough guy like his personality was a
little yeah purse I would hope well I
mean that that's why Philly probably
loved him
yeah him one of the many reasons why I
feel he loves I'm game room would get
dirty and that's what was great about
that squad cuz you had Charlie hustle
you know and a lot of the great Philly
squads even when Dykstra had his time of
prominence there like it's that Durnan
down and dirty like tough-as-nails
mentality that Philly fans love they do
love that they definitely relate to it
now are you a Villanova person too or no
not really
yeah I was I mean I love all of the
teams from that area I also remember the
Villanova Georgetown NC double-a final
from my youth and that stay with me
because I was in high school I think
then so yeah I mean this year in spilly
sports and when and we had we had the
sitter's in the playoffs
it was amazing man to go from the Super
Bowl the Flyers were in the playoffs the
Sixers were in the playoffs Villanova
wins the n-c-double-a
Phillies are two and a half games out of
first it's a good time to be a Phillies
about to say that's pries and why I'm
bringing it up again a shooter premiered
last Thursday a season three on USA
Network which you can catch every single
Thursday night including tonight at
10:00 p.m. Eastern Time we have to
excuse me I don't even know what the
hell day it is anymore that's fine I was
up till 2:00 in the morning playing beer
pong with post Malone's so I'm a little
out of it too which by the way I had no
idea the amount of rules the complexity
of the rules that etiquette of beer pong
let's see I didn't have the collegiate
fraternity experience so this is all new
to me so he they're teaching me last
night
all of these beer pong terms and rules
okay I think we need to start from
scratch here you were you're you were
playing beer pong with post Malone where
was this it was MBT it was before and
after his show at the Hollywood Bowl
how do you know him I've known him for
about three years I directed a couple
videos for post but I met him three
years ago when white Iverson his first
single was out and nobody knew who he
was
everyone was predicting he'd be a
one-hit wonder he had no tattoos
in fact it's on my Instagram today the
photo of when he and I first met and
then from last night and last night you
see the tattoos all over his face and
hands everything so it's funny to see
how a guy couldn't go from you know no
unknown to superstar in three years in
music it's crazy okay so the beer pong
that's what he likes to do to relax
before and after the show like literally
he was playing in a beer pong match
against my friends he goes oh I gotta
get ready get five minutes before his
shows starting right so ten minutes
later he's on stage saying the show ends
back to the beer pong that's that's five
all right so let's take a 60-second
break and we'll come back and then we'll
get into this beer pong rules and we'll
dig in deeper and then obviously you
know you're Eagles win the championship
that's why I brought up Villanova I mean
it is it is a great time to be a Philly
sports fan especially if in the next
week LeBron James joins that scene which
i think is entirely possible your lips
to God's ears
okay Brian Philippi of shooter season
three on us a back at 60 seconds
[Music]
all right welcome back to Rich Eisen
show we were about to go down a little
bit more of a Philly sports wormhole
with Ryan Philippi of USA Network
shooter but then you stopped us on the
track saying that you were playing beer
pong last night after the Hollywood Bowl
show of robert post Malone you've known
for three years so what what are the
rules
cuz I think everybody's games of beer
pong have different rules I don't think
there's any hard and fast rules I think
there's some pretty official rules and
in fact like I went on the internet this
morning so I could refresh myself okay
so I could remember some of the terms
okay but yeah I think there is a
standardized way to play and also my
playing is sort of a misnomer I was more
of the line judge post was demanding
that I check people's elbows there's
this whole thing where the elbows can't
cross the table it's these guys are very
serious about it like I said we were
putting money down I think the pot got
up to a thousand dollars oh my god um
but there's this whole thing like
rebuttals like so if you win the game
then the other team you it's it's like
up to you if you're the winner to give
the other team opportunities it kind of
sort of mmm challenge back there's all
these sort of gentlemen's requests about
changing the shapes of the cups as the
game's progress now see it's been a
while Brockman how long was the last
time you played see you know it seems
like the things have advanced like I
think technology might be better in
terms of plastic if the cops might be a
little bit more forgiving you know
others leaks like professional leagues
do you know about that I don't yeah and
I think that's why these rules had to be
sort of determined now if it was there
anybody I guess reason why I'm asking
this shooting this by with any phone
because that may that way instant replay
could be brought into was there any
video yeah I took a lot of video I think
that's where it gets a little more
informal you kind of turned to the
gallery and there's a consensus arrived
upon but I think that's one of the place
where the rules get was anybody trying
to influence your
your lines lying judging AB s'posed was
absolutely and because it was his
concert he kept saying that he goes this
is my concert if I say it's out it's
like oh my god throw up your hands okay
so now where did you take in the Super
Bowl this year were you in were you in
Minnesota were you or not no I I had the
opportunity to go to Minnesota but we
were in production on the series and I
was still healing from a broken leg last
last summer so it seemed a little
arduous especially with the cold and I
like watching in the comfort of my home
I feel like you can analyze the game
better live it seems to go by so quickly
and I like to know the intricacies and
nuances of who's hurt whether they're
coming back into the game all of those
things that you kind of miss when you're
when you're there watching it live and
so what was what did it mean to you I
mean who were all what do I mean what
did it mean to you I was sitting with my
14 year old son watching the game
throughout with only a couple I didn't
want too many people because I didn't
want distractions I wanted only people
football minded focus people talking
Brock Brockton's language I'm not going
to one of those parties where you're
explaining the game to casual fans or
like you know people don't understand
the importance you know and so I watched
it in my theater and even with the
broken leg at the end of the game I'm
jumping I have video of that and I left
the ground it's like two feet off the
ground at the end of that game and it's
unforgettable and also to have your son
right there with you and then we got on
the phone with my dad back east and
facetiming with him my dad's got tears
and he's not the type of guy to cry but
he's been waiting for this moment for
seventy years you know it's really
special when when it does happen and the
most emotionally affected I got was
watching the parade and Jason Kelsey
speech was unbelievable
momma's gear is mother either before
they got to that seeing the people of
Philadelphia knowing what it meant to
the mentality of the city to the you
know the future of the city in some ways
that the that really struck me just
knowing how desperately the people
wanted it you look like you're getting a
little choked up I could he's got a
little bit of a touch of the Vermeil
right here for me a touch of the Vermeil
I'll take that that's a common touch of
the Vermeil talking about your Eagles
winning the whole damn hey next week yes
I'm getting to go to the
facilities and take a photo holding the
Lombardi my son and I are gonna go why
not wait man I cannot that is gonna be
all over Instagram that's about to say
sweet ass a photograph I will absolutely
do that so you're gonna go there and
just Hank I guess this yeah this it's
kind of all quiet right now before
everybody comes back yeah they get back
into the offices on the 9th if the
trophy actually gets engraved in the
12th and so we're gonna try to see it on
the 10th or 11th before they send it a
pre engraving for you engraving Lombardi
hold they offered me the option to get
one of the rings it wasn't it was a
Philly special ring but it's meant to
look like the real Eagle Superbowl ring
the real McCoys probably it's just it's
a little bit more than whatever beer
pong was that okay yeah you know but hey
you said to me back in the in the
dressing room how much you love duck I
love Peterson and I love what a call man
the Philly special the part about the
thing it because the the and while we're
also on the subject of all things
Philadelphia right across the river that
has co-opted the Rich Eisen no no no no
in Mount Laurel New Jersey were NFL
Films resides which is technically I
mean it's practically a Philly
institution as well john facendo is a
broadcaster there for so many years
Harry Callas Harry Callas that the fact
that they were that they had the moment
that the moment that was revealed that
it was foals
who suggested it and that the backstory
being that they had it keyed up against
Minnesota they had it keyed up and ready
for Minnesota and obviously they didn't
need to use it because of the score the
fact that at that moment that Peterson
calls timeout and I thought at the time
they had called timeout because they
were gonna do it virtually every other
team does against New England which is
settled for the three got to take the
points and you play into New England's
hands when you do that all the time the
fact that he calls timeout and and
Bowles is the one who goes up to and
suggests the the play and Peterson
pauses for a second he goes yeah that's
why he's such a terrific the casual
nature of that interaction grows my mind
and I he's big balls big balls Doug man
that's we call him back home I mean he's
got he's got it
you need that not only to beat New
England on a stage like that but also to
succeed in Philadelphia he's calling in
the show a couple times I've gotten to
have conversations with him you know
away from a camera or phone yeah and the
team race and he's a person that don't
loves him you know and I think that's
one of the most crucial aspects of
coaching in sports is you know the guys
believe in your program right the guys
like who you are in the way you treat
them and then you get good results all
right in the few minutes we have left
here to chat Ryan philippi here on the
Rich Eisen show shooter season 3
premiered a couple of Thursday's ago and
you can catch it tonight 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time on USA Network
so LeBron coming to your squad yeah what
do you think here I made it's the most
exciting idea notion it's you were
talking about one of the greatest
basketball players ever to play the game
what would I think we'd be a title
contender immediately absolutely you
know I've heard that he looked at
schools for his kids in Philly but I but
you know there was there's so many
rumors it's hard to park but we're gonna
know very soon I know we are I know hey
look you know Kobe played high school
basketball in the area okay turned out
well for him yeah I did yeah I think
when it's all said and done he's gonna
look around a landscape and we played
the soundbite in our first hour of our
show oh you were driving here from
Maverick Carter who's LeBrons longtime
friend and business partner and he he's
locked in he was here last November and
he said he's gonna go to a place where
he can win that's it hmm that's where he
wants to winning is what sells
everything else and what's the best
opportunity to win to me it is leaving
Golden State for last so that means the
East yeah and what is his best
opportunity to win in the East I don't
think the Celtics are gonna be available
for him to go to know who has the
ability to win now the Philadelphia
seven series I mean out of everybody
else that has a roster already made with
young players he can grow around with a
legacy I mean here in in Los Angeles
he'd be one of many Lakers there he
would be up you know he's a heroes you
know
just like that in a way yeah yeah but
dr. J Allen Iverson I mean in terms of
guys who won it all I mean there's no
the players that we already have there
have variant styles to his and I think
we complement his very well I think that
I think they'd be such a fun and
exciting team to watch because we have
great ball movement already in the way
the Ben Simmons can dish and and handle
I'd love to see the two of them passing
back and forth to each other would be
not him and embiid - yeah just to finish
it I know I know
alley-oops from LeBron - embiid it's
like a dream if there was only a burner
account that could give us some insight
into what might happen we got rid of
that so is one of the weirdest sports
stories in a long Wow yeah it's bizarre
I mean yeah it is and now the general
managers position is available for maybe
them to hire the guy who was the GM when
LeBron won at all for David Griffin I
mean there's a lot of times where you're
thinking
before I let you go let's talk shooter
again one week ago tonight is when the
season 3 premiered what do you expect in
season 3 and we talked a little bit with
the television audience but now the
radio audience is here about shooter
season three well you know the thing I
love most about our show is that each
episode feeds directly into the next it
moves very quickly and so you get a lot
of bang for your for your hour that you
that you choose to watch our show and
the actions relentless every single
episode we've got something that's gonna
surprise you something that you didn't
expect and it's a great cast Omar and
Cynthia and Chantelle even though all
marzo Cowboys fans it's about to say
yeah but actually dumar was here
recently promoting his book he was
information he mentioned how much he was
in trusting Jerry Jones to get the
roster right because he has a track
history on that front it's funny where
to feed kind of lit up when he said that
is that right oh yeah a little bit it's
funny how Eagles fans and cowboys fans
kind of you know hate the respective
team the opposite teams but he and I
like each other so much so we kind of
set it aside we kind of goodnight Oh who
the Cowboys pick up oh that would be
good for your team you know it's we act
like
hashtag people we're talking about here
so you guys put that aside on the set of
shooter yeah we do we talk a lot of
football we took a lot of football and a
lot of old-school hip-hop a lot of
hip-hop in general I remember when the
Pusha T disc came out we were on set
listening to it on my phone like two
little kids I go my god in between takes
but yeah he and I get along really well
and his book from fatherless to
fatherhood is excellent and great read
for dads yeah we weed that's what he was
here talking about promoting
self-published which is no joke he's an
impressive dude Omar no joke right
so again premiered last Thursday June
21st it airs Thursdays 10:00 p.m.
Eastern on USA Network and yes sir this
being a Thursday see you tonight tonight
thanks for coming back man anytime rich
please do so do you have him you haven't
what Mitch Williams next time you'll
wear I'll wear my wild things what else
what else you got what else does that
that's in that's part of your your
wardrobe yeah Mitch Williams yeah I've
got a Mitchell and mostly I have Eagles
jerseys I have Mike quick can I've got
like I've got Reggie white jerseys all
right you know I'll switch it up I'll
surprise very good good to see you
brother you got it at Ryan Philippi on
Twitter and that's also your Instagram
as well okay check it out the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience